hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute zusammen mal wieder ab dabei ist
glaube ich gerade mein hals komplett
kaputt gegangen dem scheint das echt
erzählt ich ganz schön neu zu gefangenen
der plan für heute wird sein ausgehen
also einen spaziergang machen heißt
meine ich mir wurde nämlich unglaublich
häufig in die kommentare geschrieben wie
man wirklich in den park gelangen kann
denn da muss man wohl so weit aus dem
meer ausgehen dass man im park findet da
ist ja sogar eine arena oder ist der
partie eine andere richtung oder und
nächsten tag das problem ist halt ich
weiß nicht ob ich nach dem park noch
nach hause kommen das sie gerade
geöffnet würde das nur ganz knapp
funktionieren das ist so ca die längste
route die wir glaube ich den kompletten
in den boxen ein
ich brauche größere rolle spiele ja
immer noch mit dem gedanken irgendwann
mal ein postfach für kurze zeit
einzurichten dass ihr alle sachen die
ihr weil ich lese so ich hab viel stoff
auch gar nicht gesehen habe ich mir
gedacht war für eine woche oder so ein
postfach im mund aufzumachen aber das
dauert noch da bin ich jetzt gar nicht
aber lewis wieder so ein typischer balu
halt da bin ich noch am überlegen ob ich
das wirklich machen soll aber der hund
aber sie laufen auf häufig noch der typ
ist ck am verhungern und muss trotzdem
noch pissen balu schon wieder zwei mal
in einem meter aber wir sind jeden
moment im park angekommen da müssen wir
nur noch ihren bitten
du hast den park erreicht hier ist genug
mal kurz den ball rüber um diese kommen
die anderen was wollen denn jetzt pauli
und camiro hier neben balloon ist der
einzig coole hier ihr könnt alle ihr
könnt ist balu fast fassbar nun
nicht mal schön auf sport und auch rote
disc und die jetzt bei luchs als er
diese fucking anderen hunde regen
michels auf alu steht da vorne voll im
abseits und nein ich will nicht mit dir
trainieren ihr ballon
kann ich die anderen hunde irgendwie
töten ich habe mein neues ziel gesetzt
ich will diese anderen scheiß töten
töten
dass die klauen um eine blöde disc einig
welche park verlassen kommen da jetzt
noch immer du [ __ ] balu was kommen wird
hier nimmt ballon wollt ihr blöden pizza
wahlkampf an
ich bring dir der gerüchte nintendogs
labrador können die hunde sterben
nintendogs von wegen niedlich und
verspielt gta 5 tiere töten doch
schultern 100 auf mädchen intendant
peter gegen activision hier steht nicht
wie man hunde töten können möchte das
noch gar nicht in der gegenwart von dem
balu mir sagen weil er sonst nicht im
volk sagen wir aber bei loup da schon
wieder die disc von mir anfangs den
fängst du den fängst du dann fängst du
der ist mir schon so oft runtergefahren
jetzt nach vorn und ich hasse diese
scheiß töne und balu fängt jetzt die
ja wir werden immer besser aber wir
gehen jetzt mal wieder nach hause denn
ich denke der bande hat definitiv genug
gelernt wie heute und wir versuchen
jetzt mal auf dem rückweg nicht an dem
geschenk vorbei zu laufen sondern kommen
ballo ballo das ist der ist doch echt
behinderte balu und wir sind während der
ball jetzt auch sein schön verdientes
wasser ein wenig trinkt kann ich euch ja
schon mal sagen was in der nächsten
folge machen werden und zwar werde ich
ein paar sachen einfach im shop
verkaufen zum beispiel kameras und so
was alles weil man darf man nur noch ein
bisschen geld bekommen sehr viele leute
den kommentar trink doch kein wasser aus
sehr viele leute meint in den
kommentaren dass man dafür tatsächlich
ein bisschen geld bekommen könnte wovon
ich mir dann neue kaufen kann und es
gibt vielleicht im nächsten part schon
neues welt beginnt haben bin ich mir
aber noch nicht bei sicher wenn euch
dieser patente aus gefallen hat will ich
mich über eine wertung freuen
das macht er irgendwie immer am ende
neuerdings verpiss dich doch